the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like this is about to
be another very exciting day after
waiting for nearly three years it's all
finally starting to happen
once again hbo has released another
house of the dragon teaser video and as
always everything looks absolutely
incredible we're now only about one
month away from finally seeing westeros
on our screens again and i know i'm not
alone when i say i cannot wait in the
new video released by hbo we hear some
words from miguel sapochnick who not
only directed three episodes from house
of the dragon's first season but he's
also one of the showrunners as well
some of you might remember him from his
directing days on game of thrones he's
directed some of the greatest episodes
like hard home the battle of the
bastards and the winds of winter
we also hear from ryan condell who is
one of the co-creators of house of the
dragon alongside george rr martin he is
also the other showrunner alongside
miguel sapochnick as well
now during the new video we hear ryan
say how much he was influenced by george
rr martin's writing this is something i
have went over before in some of my
other videos what i love about ryan the
most is the fact that he seems to be a
student of a song of ice and fire
whereas the old game of thrones writers
david and dan only seemed like they were
fans of george's writing i'm a super fan
and i i found the books
at this point over 20 years ago
and i loved them i was a huge uh uh
tolkien fan lord of the rings just that
you worshipped at the at the at the
altar of it uh the movies were coming
out and i had i just reread them and i
was in this kind of fantasy mode and i
was like what else is out there and a
friend had recommended hey if you love
tolkien you should really check this out
because it's it's really the only it's
the it's the it's the only thing since
tolkien that really got me up out of my
seat fantasy-wise i've liked other
fantasies i've enjoyed things uh there's
some great classic books out there but
nothing to me held the candle to to
tolkien but this did and it was of
course the first book game of thrones
and i read it and i just i fell all the
way in i was all in like you know i i
couldn't believe how good it was i i
read all three there were three books at
the time storm swords that just had just
been published and i just devoured them
and then went back and devoured them
again and i and it just it became my
favorite thing so and this happened at a
time where i was learning to to write
myself uh i was very interested in
screenwriting i'd written a couple of
scripts i was starting to try to make a
a career of this i was in my early 20s
and um you know cut to a number of years
later i'm not i've now broken in i still
love these books i'm a huge fan of the
television show i'm watching it all i
tried to get at some point i tried to
get my agents to get me a staff writer
job on the show and they were like they
don't have staff writers it's just the
two of them write the whole show
so um i respected him so much and
actually learned so much from him as a
writer because i i mean i credit even
though the
the books are prose books george started
as a dramatic writer a screenwriter
intelligence the books are written in
this comment dave you've read them
they're written in this incredibly
cinematic way with hooks at the end of
chapters there's dialogue i mean it's
written you could very easily just put
slug lines into those books and create
scenes out of them it's not a novelistic
style of writing so i learned a lot
about character and storytelling and
atmosphere and theme and all these you
know
literary tools like you know
foreshadowing and how to you know how to
write prophecy compelling prophecy that
doesn't seem you know uh
dinky or foregone conclusion all these
things that i i still use today that i
learned from those books so it was just
really exciting for me to be able to
meet george and then we and then we hit
it off and then you know on down the
road we go you know some you know five
six seven years later it turned into a
job offer which still i mean as still it
still
blows my mind that i'm that i'm sitting
here doing the show during an interview
with ryan and george ryan more or less
said he has studied a song of ice and
fire and in doing so it helped him learn
how to write stories of his own when i
heard that it had me very excited for
house of the dragon because it really
does seem like they found the best man
for the job that is if you ask me near
the end of the video we also hear george
rr martin say he wanted ryan to write on
the show because he knew ryan knew his a
song of ice and fire novels better than
any of the other writers hbo originally
wanted on the show
a round of development
if you go back
when it was clear that the game of
thrones was ending that dave and dan
wanted to end it after seven seasons or
something
hbo started looking to develop other
other shows
and um the two that i pitched were
dancing with a dragon which became
uh house of dragon and uh
the dunkin egg thing
but there were a number of other shows
that were developed at that time
most of them put together by writers
that hbo hired
uh
who had never read my books
and who i guess had watched the show and
they were doing and when we were getting
into this i didn't want that anymore i
obviously none of those shows ultimately
got on the air i thought you know i want
people if they're going to be working in
my world i want them to actually have
read my books and i liked ryan's work
and i knew they knew the world he had
read the books so
once again in that bar at the four
seasons uh yeah where it all
started
as a fan of a song of ice and fire this
makes me confident that house of the
dragon will be a faithful adaptation as
well as the fact that they have george
rr martin helping them along the way now
since george rr martin says he's in good
hands with ryan and miguel i have no
reason to believe otherwise
during the teaser video we also see some
new shots of the different sets from the
first season
some of you might not agree with me on
this but i think the new iron throne
looks stunning even the great hall where
the iron throne sits looks even larger
and more grand than before it honestly
looks like each episode will have a 100
million dollar budget almost everything
about house of the dragon seems larger
than life
this first season will look so much
better than game of thrones first season
in nearly every way i just hope the
story itself is nearly as good
now i know i'm biased when i say this
but i think house of the dragon will
blow the new lord of the rings series
out of the water i just can't help but
be in shock while looking at these new
sets it really does feel like we are
entering into a fantasy world while
watching this show
that's one of the reasons why i love
game of thrones so much because it was
so easy to immerse myself into the story
because everything felt so real not only
are the sets incredible but so is
everyone's wardrobe it looks like
they're all wearing something straight
out of a louis vuitton or versace store
i mean it actually looks like something
you would see at a royal wedding but
then again maybe that's just me all i
know is i'm very excited for the world
of westeros and a song of ice and fire
once again
get ready for the next chapter in the
game of thrones saga house of the dragon
my friends is almost here
make sure you subscribe now so you can
stay up to date on any and all
information regarding game of thrones
and house of the dragon now that we're
only about a month away there will be
many more videos heading your way i'm
only just getting started as always i
want to thank everyone for stopping by
and watching my video i hope you will be
here for my next one have a great day
everyone i will see you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you